today I want to stick to football we're
gonna have some fun you get all three
host all week long Thank You Spring
Break we are gonna start breaking down
our positional big boards today wide
receivers tight ends and the DB's
corners and safeties Matt Melo Connor
watch us on YouTube subscribe a podcast
at your Spotify but fellow so we got to
start the show with some news austin
Eckler who a couple years ago was a guy
at a western state I don't even know
what college that's in or psyche date or
state uh yeah that's what I meant by
that I think it's how I write it is I
believe yeah and I think you're right he
is signed basically because an area
scout vouched for him the I read this
Peter King wrote they were gonna bring
in one undrafted free agent they wanted
Corey Clement but he went to I think the
Eagles instead so a scout says hey no
there's this guy at Western State they
get Austin Eckler over the weekend the
LA Chargers signed him to a four-year
twenty five million dollar extension
good bye Melvin Gordon exactly i I think
that Melvin Gordon if he could go back
to the offseason and replay this whole
free agency holdout thing that he did I
know he's even said he would do it
differently but man works out for Austin
Eckler here who's had a really good
start to his career and now the guy goes
out and he gets paid didn't miss any
games that's the way to do it if you're
running back I thought it was kind of
cool that Melvin Gordon still gave him a
big congrats on Twitter because that's a
tough one to swallow when you know it
comes down to it Eckler got the job done
when Gordon was not there but I think
when you look at Austin Eckler seven
yards away from being a thousand-yard
back next year that has so much value in
the league right now when you look at
what he can do on the field I thought
this was a really good deal for both
sides guys I mean you talk about a
player that wasn't drafted to go get
that you know second running back
contract that still big money at the
position contract but for the Chargers
to keep things in line and not come out
and tie yourselves to you know money for
a very very long term at a ridiculous
price like we've seen with Devon to
Freeman Todd Gurley levy on bail so I
think for Eckler and the Chargers this
still makes sense for both sides really
does in for a guy who's so versatile he
played 25% of his snaps at wide receiver
I mean he could play
this is where the NFL is going and I've
had conversations with pro personnel
guys we talk about what type of running
back are you gonna give a second year a
second deal to this is the kind of guy
the Christian McCaffrey is the Austin
hecklers guys who can catch the ball of
the backfield because that's always
going to be valuable even if you start
to see a little wear and tear on the run
game or you start to split snaps you're
still gonna be valuable as a receiver
heckler cut ninety two passes last year
on a hundred and eight targets like
Connor said he had 993 yards receiving
so if you're a fantasy football player I
know we don't touch on that a lot I'm
sure we will this summer
Austin Eckler is the guy you want to get
very very early in that fantasy draft
for next year because I think the target
share is gonna be massive for him with
the LA Chargers one of the name making
moves Josh Norman who was cut by the
Washington Redskins that allowed him to
sign and free to see he's linking up
with Sean McDermott who was his
defensive coordinator with the Carolina
Panthers so one year eight million
dollar deal and I I'm on the side of
this that Josh Norman has actually not
been good in about three years but I
think getting back in this scheme with
Trudeau Biya swyto on one side with good
safeties behind you this was his best
chance to get back to being a top-tier
corner again familiarities big here I
actually like this for the Bills there's
also almost no risk with this one year
eight million bucks the guy knows the
scheme worst case scenario he's your
third or fourth corner I think you
talked about win-win I think that you
can bring in a veteran here like Norman
and like you said Matt throw him on the
opposite side of tree Davis why he no
longer has to guard the number one
receiver
I think Redskins fans will tell you that
wasn't working out hasn't been for a
while and it's just good to have that
veteran presence for a bills team that's
gonna be looking to make a deep playoff
run next year there are absolutely two
sides to this I think when you look at
Norman like you said Matt he's been bad
for a couple years now especially in the
red zone he has been atrocious at times
but I think on the flip side of it for
the bills you're not asking him to be
your number one corner you're asking him
to be your number two or number three
corner across from what might be the you
know top or second-best corner and all
football and Trey white and I think when
you look at this team they have a ton of
CAP space they're taking a flyer they're
using a very small amount of money
of that a Norman enormous amount of calf
space you know and see if they can get
anything from Norman on a one-year deal
doesn't cost them a compensatory pick or
anything like that so I think for the
bills if there was any team that could
take this risk its them and I don't hate
the move at all yeah I don't either
you don't expect him to be your number
one and we have right now no idea if the
AFC East is gonna look like next year so
I think it's smart to get someone like
Josh Norman even if it's he's gonna come
in to be kind of that elder statesman
you know he's gonna help the young guys
learn the defense he's gonna allow you
to maybe take the next step in your
defense I think that's that's a smart
move but he can do it without being a
distraction
that's probably key I mean it was last
offseason he was jumping over Bulls in
Spain III do want to say that I hope
he's not a distraction hopefully he can
come in with the bills who seemed to
have a good locker room so I don't think
that'll be an issue and I think that's
an important point something that I I
remember I'm not gonna say the geums
name a very good GM and I were talking
once about hey why don't you bring in
this guy and he said our locker room is
not ready for that guy we can't do it
and so I think with the bills that
that's a huge component of this if
you're gonna bring in a Josh Norman if
you're gonna bring in like I love Odell
Beckham but if you bring in a guy like
that your locker room has to be ready
for it
Antonio Brown had a ton of [ __ ] off the
field that wasn't related to just being
a little bit of a diva but the football
side of it you got to have a locker room
that's ready for a guy like that and so
I think that's important to the bills
they has to say a lot about how they see
Josh Allen how they see their leadership
on defense if you're gonna bring in
someone like this now we don't talk a
lot of XFL here and that's not we're not
anti XFL there's a lot going on this
time of year so it's not always easy to
find time to talk about what they're
doing on Saturdays and Sundays in the
XFL but I thought this was notable the
Seattle Seahawks are working out Houston
Roughnecks quarterback PJ Walker who has
been fantastic for the XFL coming out of
Temple he's a small dude he's a
playmaker and that has carried over to
what we've seen him do for Houston and I
think when you look at see out like this
is a great fit him being a backup to
Russell Wilson they play a similar style
of football and we've always said if you
a backup quarterback has to be a lot
like your starting quarterback so you
don't have to change anything in your
scheme
PJ Walker I think is the XFL player who
has the best chance to make an NFL depth
chart next year just because of the
familiarity with that system what you
want him to do he can do all the stuff
Russell's doing yeah and I we do get a
lot of questions about the XFL and
honestly I haven't watched hardly any of
it but I do see what PJ Walker's doing I
I see the the questions come in and like
you said I like the fact that he's a lot
like Russell Wilson and he's getting it
done with his arm it's not just he's
there running around making place it's
worth the call I don't see I don't see a
lot of XFL guys getting this call from
the NFL but Scouts are at least showing
up to XFL games and I know the XFL
probably doesn't want to think of
themself as a feeder League but that's
what these players are doing and guys
like Cardale Jones
PJ Walker maybe they can get another
look act at the NFL by having success at
the XFL I think I got a I got to ask you
guys if you're the XFL do you find a
financial way to keep your star of the
league in PJ Walker is there any way you
can go above the pay grade and make an
exception for players like him that
let's be honest he's the reason that a
lot of people turn on the TV when the
XFL is on or at least when his team
plays I think that's one thing that
makes this new CBA interesting and that
the players are voting on it as we're
speaking right now Monday morning
because the player minimum if the player
minimums get bumped up and the NFL in
the new CBA like that would make it
really hard for the XFL to compete with
that but I think you're right Connor I
think you got to find a way whether it's
through marketing dollars or whatever it
might be
to keep a PJ Walker because I mean he is
he's the MVP of this league right now
he's the star of the XFL but how do you
like for him the dream is probably to
play in the NFL you know it's not to be
the best XFL player of all time so I
think yeah you would want to find that
flexibility and I'm sure Oliver Lux
trying to figure that out but man it
that is a tough call right there and I
think McMahon probably has the money to
say you know what PJ Walker is gonna be
our MVP let's pay somehow to keep him
yeah I think you're right Connor if you
want this league to be sustainable you
don't want your guys running off to the
NFL every year I think you have to find
a way to pay PJ Walker
and get him to come back for next season
assuming I mean the XFL seems pretty
popular that they do have a next season
I just think that's my question is like
you look at it and you sit there and you
go man how many more pj Walker's is this
league gonna get and maybe I'm wrong
maybe they do get lucky and the NFL
misses on guys like this or they let
guys like this get away and these guys
get better in the XFL but I just think
establishing any kind of star I mean
let's not forget guys Cardale Jones was
supposed to be one of the stars of this
league
he got bench for Tyree Jackson this
weekend so when you look at it right I
think I do think they gotta find
exceptions somehow but I agree with you
it is not gonna be easy after the new
CBA is agreed upon a good friend of ours
Erik Galco is like running personnel for
the XFL and he covered the NFL Draft for
a long time Erik's a great guy and I
feel confident that they will find
they'll continue to find the P
jaywalkers like to me tyler Huntley is
tailor-made for the XFL like probably
not good enough for the NFL but man he
could be a beef in the XFL like Cole
McDonald Cole McDonald McDonald would be
cross he in this league with I mean it's
arm talents just don't give a [ __ ]
attitude with his arm in two years I
think he will be I think he probably
gets picked up by an NFL team next year
but yeah the year after that I fully
expect Cole McDonald to be running XFL
team right that would be great now last
thing that we're talking about before we
take a break and get into our positional
big boards anyone who's listening to
this podcast for even one episode knows
that we like to get out mix up with our
fans we like to drink some beers I don't
know if you all saw this the XFL they
did a beer snake it included according
to the XFL 1237 cups with almost 20,000
ounces of beer consumed so it's just the
snake of cups that runs down the like
down the Sun hands and Oliver Luck even
got involved that was the best partner
gets involved which could you imagine
Roger Goodell doing this a lot of other
leagues try to do this I know it's
popular in baseball and security will
not let him do it like they'll come
break up the snake they won't allow it
so the XFL the fact that they are
allowing it it's a good viral moment you
see it on Twitter or Instagram yeah I oh
that looks like a fun time that's what
the XFL needs to do embrace the part of
the you know game that the NFL won't
making a big beer snake in the stands
yeah that should be actually watching
that made me want to go to an xml game
like we have it in st. Louis not that
far from here it's like if this is what
we're doing I want to be a part of this
I mean it's ridiculously long and I
think it's one area that you know you
just said they need to emphasize but
it's one area they are doing a good job
in social media matters so much to this
league and taking on those moments that
the NFL refuses to accept whether it is
celebrations whether it's
behind-the-scenes of reviews or whether
it's fan moments like this I do think
the league just needs to soak up as much
fun and not take itself overly serious
like the NFL tends to do and that's how
maybe they'll keep a good a good fan
base around beer snake coming to the
tailgate or 2020 guaranteed we'll be
back right after this with our
positional breakdowns for the wide
receivers and tight ends
we are back in it it's time to get into
positional big board breakdowns each of
us keeps an individual board and it's
time to start unveiling this a little
bit there is still time for things to
change we're sitting here it's March 9th
we got about 45 days until the NFL Draft
so a lot could still change but for now
this is where we're at and let's start
with the receivers we're gonna give you
our top five at each position and
there's a little more difference here
than I expected so we'll just kind of
talk about our differences on guys
number one receiver from me Jerry Judy I
have a Henry rugs number two CD lamb
third t Higgins fourth and Justin
Jefferson at number five in my list not
a lot different but it does start with
Jerry Judy for me again I don't think
the gap between him and CD lamb is that
much if I look at my big board I have
them at number five and number seven
overall and then followed by Henry rug
who was actually ninth overall on my big
board after that it's still t Higgins
it's still just in Jefferson I think
that second tier of receiver is still
really close and with the pro day from t
Higgins we'll learn a lot more but for
me again I have it Judy lamb rugs
Higgins and Jefferson and I'm gonna go a
little different here I've gone back and
forth on this almost every month since
we started evaluating this class but I
do think CD lamb is the best wide
receiver in this class it is very close
I love the floor of Jerry Judy because
he is such a good route runner
but I think CD Lam dominates in every
aspect of playing the position whether
it's before the catch whether it's after
the catch his strong hands just what he
can do with the ball in his hand so I do
end up with CD lamb as the top wide
receiver in this class number two is
Jerry Judy number three is Henry rugs
mellow I like that you pointed out where
they are overall in your big board just
to emphasize how much we like these guys
because I have all of them in the top 12
of this class overall that's how good I
think these three are just in Jefferson
fourth t Higgins fifth
yeah and I'll circle back I have Judy at
five overall rugs at twelve lamb at
thirteen Higgins at twenty and Jefferson
at twenty-one so I'm up there with you
guys as well and I'll point out I'm
different than you I have rugs at number
two and the reason for me it's not that
I don't like seedy lamb I really really
do I just told him he's ranked number
thirteen overall in a year that has a
lot of good quarterbacks tackles D
lineman corners I like CD lamb my
biggest concern with him is I've not
seen him beat press coverage just
because in when you play against
Oklahoma if you press those receivers
you're asking to die defensively so I'm
not saying he can't do it I definitely
think he's physical I love that part of
his game it's just something you haven't
seen him do I think his route tree will
need work again that could happen he can
learn that on the fly I just I have more
questions with CD lamb then I have
answers with like with Henry rugs the
more I've watched him the more I walk
away I posted about this over the
weekend I think he's a legitimate number
one receiver in the NFL and I feel like
with Judy his route running is just so
special his burst off the line the way
he sinks in and out of routes and rugs
elite speed I think they're a little bit
easier in my opinion at least to just
position them in the NFL and say I know
exactly what you're gonna be I feel like
with CD if he gets in the right scheme
like if he goes to Arizona okay it's
over he's gonna be really really good
but if he doesn't go somewhere where
they're gonna basically get him open
with some route combinations I think he
could struggle a little bit and I look
at sealing verse floor here I think that
Jerry Judy is my number one guy I love
him at receiver I think he's probably
gonna catch six balls every Sunday and
be exceptional maybe not coming out
making the
plays but I think that's whose CD Lam is
I think CT Lam might catch two balls one
week and then because press coverage
you're out tree something like that but
then the next week he's gonna come out
and catch a 9 or 10 I think that he's
gonna be very good I have him comes
right now to DeAndre Hopkins I did that
during the season I'm not coming off of
I think his explosiveness after the
catch and his hands are so underrated
this dude makes some ridiculous grabs
there's the play get against UCLA that I
think everybody's probably seen but he
does that every Saturday there are a lot
of players that come through oh you and
and everybody would be like oh you
scared to watch this guy that's a Texas
fan and a lot of them I wasn't see deal
am scared me and rightfully slow his
junior year because he ran away from
five defenders by himself with no help
so CD Liam really makes me nervous as a
fan if I have to guard him cuz you don't
know what's gonna happen he's very hard
he doesn't separate in his routes but he
catches the ball in traffic and then
afterwards good luck getting ahold of
him I'm with you all the way I mean only
three drops this year only a 4.5% drop
rate which is well above average when
you look at CD lamb strong hands now
what's even crazier when you go back to
to operate rugs only dropped 2.4 percent
of his catchable passes per PFF so I
think rugs has very very underrated
hands but when you look at what CD does
I think he's just a dog before and after
the catch he's physical he'll beat up
corners even before the catch point I do
think when they rarely but when they do
try to get hands on them it's dangerous
whole body you around even though he's
not the biggest guy in the world he's
very very physical so and I think with
Judy it's the opposite it's hard to get
hands on him it's dangerous to play him
like that
I think his routes are so silky smooth
and clean and I know the testing you
know a lot of people are looking at
whether it's a shuttle and all these
numbers I just think he's a different
play speed on the field with Judy where
you kind of throw the test numbers out
the window and you look at these three I
mean I think all three are number one
wide receivers and I think in a way all
three are a bit scheme proof now with
rugs you'd like to see him get in a
system where they push the ball down the
field to maximize his vertical ability
but what we've seen them do underneath
is
is ability to be the quarterbacks best
friend whether it's to take a slant and
go 50 yards up the field so that's what
I love about all three of these top wide
receivers I really do think all three or
scheme proof players and moving on to
again we have we all have the same five
receivers which I feel like they have
separated themselves from the pack you
know Brandon I you KJ hammer and rhaegar
wherever you want to whoever you want to
say is your sixth I feel like these five
have separated themselves I still really
like t Higgins I know he was like yeah
I'm not I'm not combining guys it's not
resting okay cool just dominate your pro
day now and with Justin Jefferson I
think that like as much as we've talked
about oh this scheme was perfect for Joe
burrow it was also perfect for Justin
Jefferson and I do see him like he's a
great route runner he ran much faster
than any of us expected with that for
four three but I see him as like some
offenses he's gonna have to play in the
slot some offenses can we go play
outside I compared him to Davante Adams
before the combine you know not always
the best hands I think I think I saw he
dropped like seven passes this past year
which is a little bit of a concern but
also that's a high octane offense where
they're throwing the ball 4045 times the
game I think T Higgins and Justin
Shepherd Center gonna be really good for
me with them though it is a little bit
more about where they go
I could see T Higgins I can see him
being AJ Green I could see em being Josh
dachshund like I worry about that and
not agree can e separate is he easy just
a jump ball guy I think there's there's
enough concern there yeah - he's still
20 on my board I don't I'm not talking
having 26 on my board so I like him a
lot too
I think the offense really just catered
to what they had and you can't blame a
guy like that you look at Alabama it's
the same thing there they just catered
to what they had with these elite level
receivers and then Justin Jefferson
running the 44 at the 40 shows some
athletic ability I think that was a
question coming into the combine was
what he was gonna run I think a lot of
people probably would have said four or
five before we really saw him run but at
his size with his speed late in the
first round I'm taking a chance on him I
go back to something you said mad about
T Higgins the spectrum that I really
like I think it's something that maybe
we don't do enough for the draft
community doesn't do enough Josh
dachshund
to AJ Green that just goes to show you
the variance of the floor and ceiling of
that player and I completely agree
because when T Higgins is healthy and
against top competition he really does
look like a.j green in college but when
you talk about maybe some of the
translation questions of the NFL the
Josh dachshund comps are fair because
you wonder is he gonna be able to run by
people Willie just catch the ball over
everyone and then you look at Justin
Jefferson this is a player I compared to
Devante Parker who has really found his
groove in Miami I just think with
Jefferson the catch radius is phenomenal
it really really is I think he had a lot
of good opportunities whether it was in
the slot or verse off coverage in a
scheme that gave players more space than
we've almost ever seen in college
football but he still maximized those
opportunities whether it was making
contested catches whether it was what he
did after the catch just a complete
player that he was so it goes to show
you how great these top five guys are I
have all five of them in my top 20
overall players yeah really good about
my comps right now because as you guys
are talking I have T Higgins comp to AJ
green and I have Justin Jefferson comped
to Devante Parker oh there we go funny
is I don't know if people know it's like
I can't see mellows rankings and I don't
have access to Connors big board so this
is some works collaborative like we each
have our own [ __ ] that we keep separate
from each other so that we can have real
conversations about players so it is
interesting let's move to the tight ends
tied him one for me Cole commit to
Bryson Hopkins and I shared this on
Twitter I was doing scouting calls last
week and I mentioned that I have Hopkins
my tied in two and a scout hit me but
like we're on the phone he's like we
have him as our number 11 tight end so
there is a big variance in tight ends
this year three for me Adam Trotman from
Dayton for Harrison Bryant five Devan
asius how do you I don't know his name
Devon I see you see a CSC that's what I
thought and then I was then I doubted
myself from UCLA who's just a very very
good athlete and I think it's important
to note that like Bryce and Hopkins yet
drop the ball a little bit too much this
year I put that like with jaylen
ryegrass quarterback I think a lot of it
is is just bad balls where
okay yeah hit his hands he should have
caught it and I do knock him for that
but I think if he's with a better
quarterback like that type of athlete
it's hide in could be just a difference
maker so I think better quarterback play
would help but for me Cole commit is the
dude and then there's a pretty big drop
after that but I I think it's notable I
do not have any of these guys ranked in
the top 32
Kolka managed at 46 Hopkins the 88
Troutman's at 93 Bryant at 101 and a CSC
at 102 so we're talking like round 2 too
late 3 is where I would wear I would
draft these guys I think they will be
picked earlier yeah and I'm with you
with the Cole commit I think that he's
the maybe one of the only tight ends
that I say all right he can play in line
and catch the ball I love his size I
mean 6 6 262 I really like what he can
do there I second round though I have
him 40 overall he's my number one tied
and number 2 tied in for me I'm going
Alberto from Missouri
I love his athletic ability you know he
can catch the ball and I think early on
in his career at Missouri they didn't
ask him to do much in the blocking game
but I think with his size and his
strength he has that natural play
strength that he can develop more as a
blocker and play more in line number 3
for me I've Bryson Hopkins with a lot of
worries now I worry about that play
strength I think that he's probably
gonna be more of a slot tight in not too
much in line Adam Troutman is a guy from
Dayton who small school guys I don't get
around to him until spring honestly I
haven't watched much of him but the more
I watch him the more I do like him and
he's he's going up my board I think that
he probably ends with that tied in to or
tied in 3 before this is all said and
done and the fifth tight end who I don't
see on either of your guys's rankings
Colby Parkinson from Stanford another
guy that I love his size I don't love
this tight in class but I look at Colby
Parkinson and I think this is a guy they
can play for six or eight years in the
league come in be your tight into your
tight in three and occasionally be a
good pass target yeah this is not a
great tight end group this is not like
the receivers we just ran off where
we're sitting there and going hey all
five guys belong in the first round this
is the opposite because I don't think
any of these guys go in the first round
but if any do it'll be the universe
stick to football tight end number one
that is colle commit feels like the
safest option a really good inline
player a really good red zone player and
he's got a lot of potential working as a
big bodied seen target so I really do
like Cole commit I think a top 40 makes
sense for him this is where it starts to
go downhill and you're just you're gonna
get you know your bargain bin shopping a
little bit Hunter Bryant stays ismai
tight end to very disappointing combine
put on too much muscle looked slower
than he played his play speeds very good
he's a very effective pass catcher I
don't know if he wanted to show teams
that they can use him in line and he put
on too much muscle I don't know what it
was with Hunter Bryant but I still do
like him as a pass catching option
earlier in the year I compared him to
Evan Engram with those testing numbers
he is not I think he's much closer to
Gerald Everett who was a third round
pick of the Rams a couple years ago
titan-3 Harrison Bryant tight end for
Devin a CSC and tight end five Albert oh
who actually is the riser from the
combine after that blazing 40 with
Alberto he could be a gem for a team in
round three four or five but he just has
to stay on the field yeah that's the key
for him I loved watching him play when
he was on the field it just did not
happen very often was crazy isn't as
much as I like Cole commit like if I had
to bet on one of my five guys being an
all-pro it would actually be Adam
Trotman and I I said this I didn't
remember if it was on the show but I
think if maybe it was on Twitter people
got really mad at me there's some George
Kidal to his game he plays violent he is
pissed off constantly on the field and I
love that about him he can block he's a
pretty good athlete so I think Melo said
this if trauma ended up my number two
tight end by the time we get through
charting these tight ends are looking at
drop rates and things like that I would
not be surprised but again it's like
that level of competition is just it's
really really low but then you see what
he did at the Senior Bowl maybe you see
what he did at the combine it's like
damn it this let's do can play a little
bit yeah I really like what I've seen
out of him so far and being able to see
him at the Senior Bowl which is another
reason why you know a guy like Bryson
Hopkins I did not like what he did at
senior I did not feel like he had a good
week and I still question
what kind of Titan is he can't he block
is he gonna have to play in the slot is
he a move tied in I don't have those
questions about a lot of the other guys
that are on my list doesn't it feel like
if you could pick an offense for each of
these guys you can make them successful
but since we can't like since you can't
say all right Adam Trotman is gonna go
off the top my head of course I can't
think of somebody like he's gonna go to
the Colts where we know they're gonna
use him well they're gonna let him play
some inline some flex they're gonna he's
gonna get a ton of targets over the
middle of the field and like I could
make that work for him or like your guy
Hunter Bryant like if you put him in the
right offense he could be an impact but
since we don't get to do that say it
really feels like what the tight ends
you're rolling the dice I just think
when you look at this group a lot of
them are their ceiling is as a tight end
too because a lot of them can't block
right and a handful of them have drop
issues and then a guy like Troutman who
you know did a lot of good things at
that level I don't necessarily know how
to evaluate him at Dayton when he goes
and runs a 4 8 which is almost like not
passing the threshold number one Isaac
Nauta ran really bad that's what which
Troutman I had the same surprise where
I'm like man really nice career at
Dayton really tough blocker really tough
pass catching option he has plenty of
experience in college over the years but
then you go to the combine ago is he
gonna run by anyone or is this a player
that we have to scheme open as a tight
end - yeah I one thing that has stood
out to me as I've been digesting the
combine numbers a lot of them don't
correlate like with Jerry Judy like his
short shuttle was terrible like that's
not who he is really bad Troutman like I
don't think he plays like a 4:8 guy I
mean he's great six-five 255 like he's a
big boy
but I think he plays a lot faster and
his three-cone was like one of the best
you're gonna find for a tight end so
it's like this year's combine numbers
are just [ __ ] confusing yeah we might
have to just look at them like next year
and just throw them out I mean I got
this schedule whatever it was the
surface I don't know but you're right
the combine numbers are just so up and
down and inconsistent when you look at
the tape verse the player Jerry Judy I
feel like is the best example
because I have no concerns about his
agility and when you look at that
three-cone it's like what the hell
happened did he fall down was he hurt
what did he cramp up in the middle of it
I don't know but very inconsistent
combine testing here's one last one for
you guys if you were ranking chase
Claypool as a tight end in this class
where would he stand number one yeah I
think so yeah I think he probably would
too and you know big country and I were
even watching him at the Senior Bowl we
went down we went to watch the receivers
and say holy [ __ ] look at this Notre
Dame kid block like he was killed
oh he's nasty blocking and we even got
to the chance to see him verse Lamar
Jackson's from Nebraska who's a good
size corner and Claypool was owning him
and I think that's probably where this
talk started of maybe this guy moves too
tight in and then you see him way in at
the combine you're like holy [ __ ] he has
tied in size so yeah I'm with you I
think that he could end up being the
best tight end if that team drafts him
and decides to move him there we're back
in it's time to talk corners and there
is a there's a top corner in this class
and there's no argument about that I
think everyone who Scouts will agree
unless you're just like trying to be
different so number one corner for me
Jeff Okuda number 2 CJ Henderson from
Florida 3 Jeff Gladney from TCU for
jaylen Johnson from Utah and 5 AJ
Terrell from Clemson and mine looks
pretty similar again and I hate that but
Jeff Okuda is the clear number one at
corner I think that he could make a case
for one of the best offensive players in
this draft number 2 CJ Henderson number
3 Jeff Gladney number 4 christian fulton
and number 5 jaylen Johnson all right
here for me number one you're not going
to be surprised it's Jeff akuto by a
country mile here number two Jeff
Gladney number three christian fullen
number 4 CJ Henderson I've started to
turn come around on him a little bit
guys the more I get to watch I still am
a little lower than you guys but and
then number five jaylen Johnson so a lot
of the same names you hear across the
board I think we saw you know obviously
AJ Terrell in Matt's rankings and no
Christian Fulton so I think we'll start
there yeah I'm I was telling Mela before
the show because we're it draft 400 work
is going on if you're not from the
with that Melo our guy Jared brown and
myself we write 400 scouting reports so
when a players drafted you'll get an
alert on your phone
the Bengals just took jobber oh here's
our scouting report here's a you know a
highlight video some stats so we're
riding those scouting reports right now
with Kristian Fulton I don't know which
guy I'm getting I think he did play hurt
this year which I commend him for but
there are times where he looks like he's
this excellent press cover guy there are
other times where he's just getting run
right by if I could take Christian
Fulton's character and put it with
greedy Williams athleticism but that's
the corner I want like he's smart he's
tough really really high character I
just don't see a lot of juice to his
game and maybe the injury is that
because his combine was really good but
that that worries me a little bit I
think he would be my number 6 corner in
this draft
I like AJ Tyrell I was a big fan of his
throughout the season he got toasted in
the second half a national championship
game
well Jamar chase is the best wide
receiver in college football that's
gonna happen and I don't know that we
can hold that against AJ so you know
last year I was a big Trayvon Mullin fan
I just like Clemson corners I think but
I still liked Relan jaylen Johnson
another guy a little bit banged up but
on all of our top fives I think you have
to say he's probably the biggest riser
of this pre-draft process and when I
look at these corners I like about six
of them and as a Chiefs fan I've really
gone in on a lot of them I would like
any of these six guys to land with the
Chiefs when you look at I think the top
three I think they've kind of solidified
themselves for me
hakuna Henderson ending Gladney I really
like the way that they move their feet
their hips everything about him and then
I think that next here guys is kind of
lumped together like if I had AJ Terrell
in here instead of Christian full knew
and makes sense because he did get beat
up by one of the best receivers we've
seen last year in college football and
that happens we also saw a guy like cam
dance ler shut him down so there's some
inconsistencies there but I really like
about six of these corners AJ Terrell
being one of them Christian Fulton I'm
betting on that up side coming out of
LSU it's gonna stay healthy and that he
probably played a little banged up his
team won the national championship so if
you're going out there at 80% and
a national championship that's what you
have to do yeah I'm with you there I
think when you look at it Fulton's best
has been almost as good as any corner in
this class but the problem is as matt
said some of the lows are would have him
outside the top five for me so he falls
right in the middle at number three I
think when you look at jaylen Johnson
I just Allah I just love his ability in
a press scheme with his length and
physicality I think what CJ Henderson he
has the build and athleticism as a
premier corner I just think the
instincts are a one step behind right
now if those instincts when playing the
ball and just playing the position
overall starts a clique he's gonna be
looking like a guy that should have went
top 15 maybe there's a team in the top
15 that bets on that happening and takes
him anyway when you look at Jeff Gladney
I mean I don't know if I've seen a
corner move like this in this class
that's not named Jeff Okuda I mean he's
just once again a silky smooth guy in
coverage ultra competitive ultra feisty
that's one more thing with CJ Henderson
I just want to see a little bit more
competitiveness out of him this year I
thought even though he lost a couple
reps I thought it was there in the game
against Jamar chase just it seemed like
that matchup brought him up to a
different level where he was vocal he
was loud and he had a different edge to
his game and the guy that we haven't
even really spent any time on because we
all love him so much
it's Jeff Okuda guys I mean I've never
seen a corner go like this since I
started evaluating prospects
yeah he's special I haven't come to
Jalen Ramsey I think we're putting
number grades on players right now he's
probably gonna have a number grade
higher than any corner I've ever graded
I think he's really really special and
I'll say this a couple guys that didn't
make the list that I I think could go
earlier than we have them projected
Trayvon Diggs from Alabama
just because he's body beautiful I have
him as the number six corner just right
behind AJ trail Christian bullet was
right there and then Noah egg bonaga
knee from Aubrey who very very good
athlete I know he didn't have a ton of
ball skills in college I think those I
think we could see eight corners go in
the top 45 which last year none went
until what DeAndre Baker was the 32nd
pick 31st pick so I think we could see
corners
laughs the board yeah I think this is a
position that has a lot of top-end guys
but there's also a little bit of depth
there I mean you look at Jeff CUDA he's
the number two guy on my board right
behind his teammate chase young so I
really love him too I have him comp to
Patrick Peterson I know he's not quite
as big but I love his physicality and
his ability to run Conor like you said
I've never seen a corner since I've been
doing this as good as Jeff a CUDA so
maybe I'm just a little bit biased
because I've never seen anything like
him
all right let's move yeah let's do it
let's both jump in here move to the
safeties I think we're finally gonna get
a some heated conversation here maybe
we'll see number one for me Xavier
McKinney from Bama to grant Delpit three
Kyle Duggar from tiny lenoir-rhyne for
Antoine Winfield junior in five Ashton
Davis now I will say we all five had the
same or all three have the same five
safeties the order though is pretty
different
yeah and I'll jump into mine I have
Xavier McKinney number one overall and I
thought I was gonna be kind of
controversial with that take but I have
McKinney one Delpit two Antoine Winfield
junior three Kyle Duggar and then Ashton
Davis at five all right this is where I
get a little different from me number
one Antoine Winfield jr. number two
Xavier McKinney three grant Delpit for
Kyle Duggar who just says risen every
single month since I first heard his
name back in the fall and number five
someone that unfortunately hasn't gotten
a dual lot cuz an injury but he's a
freak athlete of free safety and that's
Ashton Davis no I think here's where the
conversation comes in we've all said
this before Greg Delpit scares the hell
out of me because if he plays like 2018
this guy's a top 15 pick if he plays
like 2019
I've told Melo I know a team that hasn't
been the fourth round so it's just all
over this place with Grant dumped it
because you don't know what you're
getting he's highs or Jamal Adams his
lows are I don't know I mean they're bad
the lows are right Kyle Duggar for me is
right there with great Delta and Antoine
Winfield jr. the only concerns I have
are the fact that he's a little bit
small five nine two hundred pounds and
he's been a hurt in 2018 and 2019 so
those are the concerns for me a guy who
always has the bloodlines his dad
amazing NFL player tough as hell and he
plays the same way
I know Melo
before he should won the Thorpe Award
there's a fantastic football player but
injury concerns are huge for me like if
he Bob Sanders his career or it's like
this dude's just so tough that he's just
knocking himself out of game it's like
that wouldn't surprise me Bob Sanders by
the way won a Defensive Player of the
Year award at safety so pretty damn good
but with Winfield I just worry that he
could literally like hurt himself out of
the league and with him same concerns I
worry that we won't ever really see him
put together a full season because he
really has struggled to do it at
Minnesota and I love this kid I mean he
really does it all I know that he's
small I don't care
Connor I've seen you talk about him
before with the honey badger comp I love
it because um he can play the run he
creates turnovers with the forced
fumbles he can intercept the ball he can
play on special teams like he does it
all when he's on the field
my only question that I don't have him
safety one or two is the injury concern
is can he put it together and stay on
the field hopefully all of his injuries
are behind him and now we see him have a
healthy NFL career because he's just a
guy that I find myself rooting for I
think those are really fair concerns I
mean on talent and overall he is my top
safety I'm rolling the dice on the bill
of health
I do think those that's something you
have to be concerned about but just as a
player in this class
no one did more in the 20 19th season to
me than Antoine Winfield jr. where the
guy you saw win a Super Bowl with the
Kansas City Chiefs
the honey badger was the same guy
playing for Minnesota this year and
Antoine Winfield jr. whether it was the
instincts against the run whether and I
love when the ball finds you in college
it's gonna find you in the NFL the ball
found Antoine Winfield hands his hands
this year over and over and over again
and he finished those plays so I love
this player high energy player it looks
like he's been watching film with his
dad since he could start walking because
he knows where the ball is going before
the players on offense do so but getting
away from him and getting into the
middle of this class where we're all a
little bit similar here the grant Delpit
discussion you guys have met - I have
met three let's just talk about what
maybe people are forget
with grant Delpit for a little bit I
think in 2018 he was the most complete
safety we had ever seen we were talking
about him in regards like Jeff a CUDA I
mean the guy was a huge he could cover
every Tynan you wanted he could probably
shut down some receivers no issues with
tackling really and then you look at you
put on the tape this year they're two
different players I mean there were in
different numbers they literally look
like two different players yep
Pro Football Focus had him with 20
missed tackles this year like that's a
huge concern for me and I don't think
that takes into account times that he
just didn't give effort and it doesn't
you talked to a lot of NFL safeties you
know the NFL safety some of the smartest
players you'll ever talk to and I spend
a lot of time with those guys and during
the national championship game multiple
NFL safeties texted me like I thought
del pote was supposed to be the guy like
why isn't he giving effort he's not even
trying to run down you know players in
that game and that's just who he was
this year and I know Delpit has clapped
back during the combine he's tweeted
about this like dude talk on the field
because your effort was just not good
this year and I know he's capable of it
with a without a doubt he is the most
physically gifted safety in this class
it just does not look like he gives
effort a lot of the time and 2018 16
missed tackles that's 36 missed tackles
in two years at some point at the safety
position you got to be able to tackle
and it just it doesn't seem like he I
don't know if it's a toughness thing
because I don't think he sheds blocks
very well either just he seems like one
of those guys that we I say it's all
time wants to be a football player he
doesn't want to play football because
the toughness aspect of his game is just
not there or you could be in the back of
his mind to keep him helps himself
healthy can you turn that on though like
can you turn that off and on I think
probably once you get to the NFL I think
when you hear that hype surrounding your
name as a sophomore in college you come
back and you think man I really don't
want to screw this up but then in the
NFL you're fighting for your job you're
fighting for that next contract you're
fighting to be that Hall of Fame guy so
I think you can turn it on turn it off I
think some players haven't been able to
but I think with Delpit I'm not ready to
write him off yet just because I love
that sophomore tape so much yeah and you
hope that a defensive coordinator at the
next
level sees what he can do in coverage
and say listen we can play this guy over
the top and he'll be a very reliable
player for us a very very good athlete
but just to round out this discussion
guys I think we have two players on the
backend here of our rankings that they
have a highest ceiling as anyone you
will ever see and they've had a great
rise this year in very different stories
with Kyle Duggar being a division 2
player and with Ashton Davis being a
former walk-on that was a track athlete
yeah and it's unfortunate we haven't
seen Ashton Davis we didn't seem as
senior bolding to see him run at the
combine I think he would performed
really really well my comp for him is
Darnell Savage junior and that's the
type of athleticism I expected probably
not the rise into the first round like
we saw last year Darnell but just a
really good well-rounded over-the-top
free safety type prospect
well Kyle Duggar is funny we had
conversations before the Senior Bowl of
like do you think this guy will play
linebacker and then all week a mobile he
played safety and he kicked ass playing
safety and returning punts like he's a
much better athlete than when you see
the size like 20 17 pounds
can this guy move but he moves really
really well we saw that his broad jump
his vertical jump is 40 it was all
really really special which shows that
explosiveness from him yeah I like both
of these got guys a lot because of their
athletic ability I think they're kind of
different players but I think at a
minimum they're that third corner that's
on your roster I think with Davis he
could even play some corner he's got the
feet for it and with Dugger Davis as
well they're gonna contribute on special
teams and they're going to develop even
more once I mean Davis if he's healthy
when he's healthy he looks very good in
the duggar like you said 217 pounds back
there returning punts being the gunner
like he's gonna do it all on the
football field
it is draft on draft time let's kick it
off here h-town showdown whoa Wow
cheaters if you guys were free agents
sorry I know Astros fans are sensitive
right now everyone cheats you guys just
got caught I'm sorry if you guys were
free agents what factors would you look
at when deciding where to sign
I think head coach scheme front office I
mean there's so much that goes in
I would want to go to a good situation
to a team that I thought was building it
wouldn't just be dollar signs for me I
think that when you're assuming let's
say I'm on that second contract I'm
gonna look for somewhere where I can go
have success on the field and get that
third contract that's also gonna be big
not just well they're paying me the most
money that's where I'm gonna go that's a
really good point I think you have to be
looking ahead to the next one when you
sign that original contract because as
we're seeing right now I mean we see
careers completely tally off because of
bad scheme fits or bad organizations or
honestly just poor motivation so I think
it ends you know where you go matters a
lot some people what matters to them is
their families where they're bringing
their families is that a place that you
want to maybe end your career or or do
you have media aspirations because if
you do maybe you want to be on a coast
or maybe in an opportune area where
there is an opportunity to start getting
engrained in media during football as
we've seen you know with a guy like Greg
Olson actually who's done it a little
bit before even retiring yeah if you
want to get media just play for the
Cowboys
that's the best way to do it I think for
me I'm so weird like you guys have all
these good reasons the first thing that
came to mind for me is I'm going to a
state with no state income ten news
that's week I'm going to Texas Florida
Tennessee like I don't want to pay that
extra 10% on millions of dollars [ __ ]
that already got payer agent three
percent you're already paying like forty
five percent federal I'm out on paying
state tax not doing it so that would
actually factor in a lot for me
and I try to any player who ever asked
me like where are free agent fit is for
them I mention that I'm like do you want
to pay that ten percent cuz if you play
for the Chiefs you're gonna live in
Johnson County
you're gonna taxed out the ass don't
like please come to Kansas City but that
tax is serious so I mean in it for me
like I have kids so fit for family would
be good
I would stay close to home like if I
were signing with a team I probably
wouldn't look outside of Kansas City
Nashville Dallas I I would stay in this
area maybe Denver's like as far as I
would go Denver be nice I'd be uh known
for that alright peeps nation is this
like the candy it is almost Easter do
you guys like those I hate them they're
just honor do you like people hundr
doesn't eat candy
peeps no I do but now I'm going with
like anything chocolate and peanut
butter if I'm going to have some candy
yeah Reese's egg oh yeah nope alright
who do you think will be the most
coveted player in the draft outside of
burrow and to it I think this is chase
young and I don't think there's any
question does it feel like we does it
like the draft community has forgotten
about chase young a little bit yes like
everybody is just so solid on him that
we're not talking about him like yep
he's one of the best we've ever seen to
it let's move on everybody agrees he's
amazing you know I appreciate that
though I don't want to talk about like I
don't want to start doubting chase Young
and Jeff CUDA I don't want to circle
back and do this thing where it's like
well here's that one play or like here's
you know or do the chase young disappear
down the stretch [ __ ] like get on
like let's just this is a good thing
that we've made it to this point yeah I
think after him it's probably Jeff CUDA
just because you know what they are
mm-hmm Isaiah Simmons I I don't know I
love Isaiah Simmons I think he's hella
clean as a prospect but I could
definitely see teams overthink it
yeah I agree I I love him number four
overall my board but I think you also
have to know how to use him I think I've
said that before on this show I don't
want to see somebody just say alright we
drafted you number four overall go play
middle linebacker that's all you do now
that's the problem with Simmons is if
you're evaluating him as just the
linebacker he's gonna be lower on your
your priority list that's the problem
yep and I god that scares me buy him
Garrett Greenlee our good friend got to
meet him in Indianapolis he and his dad
it was awesome they they came down to
hang out with this with quarterback and
offensive tackle runs going to take up
most of the top ten could we see Jerry
Judy fall to 15 and half drew Loch
Courtland Sutton and Jerry Judy all in
the same offense I'll tell ya a month
ago I would have made fun of you for
this Garrett it's not the craziest thing
ever if four or five tackles go early if
three or four quarterbacks go early and
if teams like CD lamb and like Henry
rugs it's not completely out of the
question
it could happen is it likely no but it
could happen I think it definitely could
you you kind of laid out the framework
there I'd say four
quarterbacks go four or five offensive
tackles Okuda and young are gonna go I
think you could throw in two defensive
tackles and Kinlaw and brown like we're
starting to see these receivers fall and
if you're sitting there and you don't
love them but you love the depth at
receiver I definitely think we could see
him fall to fifteen nine twelve is
interesting like what the Raiders let
Jerry Judy get by I think I would love
to know how they value this class I
wouldn't be surprised if they have Henry
rugs is the top wire I've I mean the
ghost of Al Davis is strong in that
building I'm telling you I keep going
back to this I'm starting to think rugs
is gonna be the first wide receiver
drafted it would not be a surprise right
I mean he's a copycat league every young
said this is Tyree kill with no off
field yeah yeah no to that I know I know
so great hands great hands
tossing Tyreke has bad hands I'm just
saying how great rugs catching ability
is and Connor we've met Jerry Judy we
spent a decent amount of time with him
he's like very soft-spoken very quiet
rugs is not rugs is the dude in that
wide reciever room like it's his room he
runs it so I think I think teams are
gonna like that aspect of it to where he
know the Raiders will yeah right uh I
mean yeah yeah you get Mayock and crude
and talking with him like I can even
picture just Gruden's gonna go crazy
over guys I was gushing yeah I was
looking at their last their only draft
class of Mayock for their pics were team
captains and basically almost every pic
had super high character and super high
production which I guess rugs hasn't had
super high production but you have to
take into account there's four
first-round reviews blanking with
receivers that'll all be number ones
essentially in the NFL if they could get
Henry rugs and Kenneth Murray like I
have to think that's a dream draft for
them like high character leaders
productive toughest [ __ ] yep yeah yeah
that's just such such a Raiders draft
so anyway Garret yeah it could happen
that'd be great for Denver but it would
be a surprise it means no quarries if
you have an entrenched elite starter at
quarterback what's the earliest round
you look
to draft a viable backup quarterback so
I have a theory and if I'm ever a GM
some have some owners dumb enough to
make this happen I would draft a
quarterback in the sixth or seventh
round every year I mean it's it's like
recruiting almost you take why not back
at right here
I think the earliest round I would take
one is around three you saw the Redskins
do this when they drafted RG three and
then the right you know what go ahead
and take Kirk Cousins to work that I
honestly I think it works and I think
even if you have a young quarterback if
you're looking at that round three
that's developmental guy but you might
hit and you might get a guy like a Kirk
Cousins who can come in and be a good
starter for a very long time and hackers
did this they drafted Aaron Rodgers I
think it was the next year they drafted
Brian Brom from Louisville if everybody
thought was gonna be a stud and Matt
Flynn who they ended up trading for a
really wait they traded him right I
think they traded him well anyway Matt
Flynn was a good backup for them I I
don't know how you would do it Connor as
a Jets fan you'd probably let's get as
many as we can take man I take one every
year that's the Ron Wolf theory right it
is yep yeah I remember that in his book
man I would take one every year when you
talk about how early so I've gone back
and forth on this theory a lot of times
for a while my theory was if you lose
your starting quarterback your season's
over but now I've seen backups not even
just Nick Foles but Teddy Bridgewater
I've seen backups hold the fort where
I've gone the other way I would take a
backup quarterback in the fourth round I
mean I'm this is why I'm fascinating to
see the Jake from a dilemma this year
like now there'll be teams that valium
is the starter so we'll probably go
before the fourth round but man he's a
really nice backup option in the fourth
round who will probably be over drafted
yeah I think that is really interesting
and I I remember being on the desk with
left Co and Sims when someone drafted
Aaron Murray and left go just like I
don't know this video why and I was like
you have to have a backup quarterback
and it didn't work for Aaron Murray
but like it's in the same way AJ
McCarron like you have to have a backup
not every player you draft he's going to
be a starter talking about Matt Flynn
Russell Wilson I don't think they
drafted him in the 3rd to be like hey
come in and be an
VP and run this league forever yeah but
you drop me if anyone tries to argue
with you when sam donaldson points in
three games when my home's went down
Matt more like he kept them engaged so
it's super exactly alright that Moore's
a good option really is and he's gonna
be the quarterbacks coach of the chief
soon next last question from Sam harp
what is the cause of ylvis' cachet no to
what what is the calls okay this
question is worth importantly sorry Sam
why is the viscous shame out falling on
Friday's episode I don't think he was
drafted at all in our to around mock
draft that we did friday morning for me
it's a company up its injuries
correlated to testing and the rise of
other receivers we've said all season
about tional this is a kind of a gadget
player you got to get him in the right
offense where you're scheming touches
and that scares me with a guy who now
his hurt has a very limited route tree
he's your one gonna be a jet sweep pop
pass just basically hand him the ball
type player so that worries me over you
know it didn't sell MEMS or chase
Claypool Donovan Peebles Jones even I
have those guys rated higher than Chanel
right now yeah I still like she know but
you look at him and I think it he
started to lose when with weigh-ins he
measured in a little close to 6 1 but
227 was real heavy I think even for him
that 7 pounds is a big difference maker
and then the run a disappointing 40 and
he might have been hurt and then maybe
he's gonna have you know a core injury
surgery so I think there's just a lot of
things that are kind of snowballing and
his not in his favor they make him drop
and then the rise of guys like Justin
Jefferson like I think Justin Jefferson
separated himself from a low viscous
Shana you look at Denzel Mims who was on
the rise Donovan peoples Jones jumped
almost literally out of the stadium so
there's a lot of those other guys that
are just making a name for themselves
and that pushes Shane taut down the
board yeah naturally it's gonna happen
but I think when you look at Xin all if
he goes in the third round and is one of
the best rookies next year would I be
surprised now right but four teams and
this is something we say on the show
over and
over and over again is that something
that Twitter and something that you know
even us at times the way the league
views injuries is so much more
significant than fans and media analysts
and all of those things where somebody
likes Chenal if they if medically there
are problems teams will take them off
the board in this receiver class or
they'll put him in the third or fourth
round and you know it's a shame and you
hope that he proves them wrong but
there's a lot of examples guys of
players that have had you know success I
mean here's one last year there were
teams that wouldn't draft DK Metcalfe
because of his neck he goes to the end
of the second round everyone sitting
there and going man how did this happen
and he has a phenomenal rookie season
great for DK great for Seattle I mean we
all really liked him and had him way
higher than 60 whatever he went but
that's a perfect example of the league
taking injuries very seriously if
Chennault became this year's d bo samuel
i would not be surprised like he goes to
the right team where everything he does
is underneath right he's not a deep
threat everything he does underneath if
you can put him in a scheme where that's
what he's asked to do I think he could
be really really good but if not he
could be really really like not a factor
so he's a really a polarizing prospect
where like you said fit is gonna matter
for this guy a lot alright that is our
show we'll be back tomorrow morning
Tuesday morning recording you'll get it
Wednesday morning and we have a lot to
talk about as we continue our positional
board breakdowns NFL free agency is
about to kick off with the legal
tampering window the illegal window has
been open for a while now franchise tag
news is coming down when you might have
a cba a lot going on so make sure you
are here three times a week on stick to
football we'll talk to you guys real
soon